للمره الثانيه مذكره عراقيه تطالب بالقبض
على ترامب
وامازون تعلن عن مجزره وظيفيه مرتقبه
والامير هاري واصل الجدل اخي ضربني
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
خبر عن محاوله فاشله لالصاق لقب البطل
بالقائد في الحرس الثوري الايراني قاسم
سليماني يوم الثلاثاء الماضي
طائره مسيره امريكيه والخبر اليوم بخصوص
مقتل سليمان لكن مرتبط ترامب المطلوب
امنيا للقضاء العراقي وموجود كمان شخصيه
وعلى فكره هي المحاوله الثانيه من نوعه من
القضاء العراقي للقبض على ترامب وليه عم
قول انه المحاوله الثانيه لانه من سنتين
صار نفس السيناري وتماما هو اصدار القضاء
العراقي المذكره القبض على الرئيس
الامريكي السابق بتهمه قتل سليمان
فالمذكره اللي تم اصدارا امبارح نفسك
اصداره من سنتين لكن للامانه في اختلاف
واحد في واحده وعشرين كانت المذكره لالقاء
القبض على الرئيس الامريكي
القاء القبض على الرئيس الامريكي السابق
والله اعلم وين ترامب حاليا يمكن يكون خا
او عمي خطط للهرب من الولايات المتحده
خوفا من القبض عليه من قبل القضاء العراقي
وفق تهكم المقردين
وعلى فكره بس حابب اذكركم بكلمه ترامب
2020 عندما بعد مقتل سليمان وكيف طلع امام
العالم كله قال لقد تخلصنا من الارهاب رقم
واحد في العالم بس يمكن ما كان ترامب حاسب
حساب القضاء العراقي وايران ولا فكر حتى
بلدي يمكن ان يصير له خلونا نسمع شوي من
كلمه ترامب ب 2020
ويصنع الفايبر
يسلم نفسه للقضاء العراقي
القضاء العراقي ما اختلفت ابدا عن عام
2021 انما
كمان شوفوا بعض هذه ردود الافعال
ومن بين ردود الافعال على هذه القصه
العجيبه الغريبه تم تداول فيديو للاعلام
العراقي احمد البشير مقدم برنامج البشير
شو ويبحث عن ترامب في واشنطن قبل عامين
لالقاء القبض عليه بعد اصدار مذكره
العراقيه الاولى في مثل هذا الوقت ب 2021
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا مثل ما تعرفون ان رئيسكم لواني
يبحث دائما عن تطبيق العداله واحقاق الحق
على الجميع بدون اي اييي بدون هذه لانه
واحد فوق اللعب كده
اليوم جئنا الى البيت الابيض ومن امام
البيت الابيض لكي نقوم
بتسليم ترامب ومحاوله ايجاد ترامب وتسليمه
الى مركز شرطه السعدون ترامب
اليوم سوف نبحث عن ترامبو نحاول ان نقبض
عليه
وايضا ملقى القبض عليه وسوف ونجيبه الى
العراق لكي يتم عليه تنفيذ العداله همم
مذكره اللي هي 460 جريمه قتل الماده 460
ترامب
نحن لازم حاليا
في كل المناطق اللي يتوقع انه يختبئ بها
مثلا نحاول ابحث ترامب
لا تخاف التحقيق معك تعليق بالتحقيق
التحقيق عادي مجرد سؤال جواب استفسار ربع
ساعه ورجعوه ترامب ربع ساعه ورجعوه ترامب
المذاكره عندي لا تخاف ترام
لك اطلع
ترامب
زين ايفانكا فشل الجهودنا بالبحث والقاء
القبض على ترامب
فنضطر نرجع الموضوع المركز شرطه السعدونه
مركز شرطه السعدون هو ينتخب الاجراءات
القانونيه العلاقات احنا سوينا علينا اني
كرهت جمهوريه حاولت انه اكون طباب خير
حاولت انه هو يسوي شغل مال احد مراكز
الشرطه وما دبرتها احيانا
نحن
واياكم اليوم
[موسيقى]
يبدو انه اخبار نهايه العام الماضي ما عم
تختلف عن اخبار بدايه العام الجديد
اعلنت شركه تكنولوجيا العملاقه امازون انا
بتخطط لتسريح عشره الاف موظف ولكن اللي
صار انه الاخبار اليوم اختلفت بس مش من
ناحيه التسريح لا من ناحيه العدد فالشركه
اعلنت عن ما يمكن تسميته بمجزره امازون
وانها بتخطط لتسريح 18000 موظف من متى
تجرها امازون وقسم الموارد البشريه وطبعا
يعتبر اكبر عمليه تسريح في تاريخ الشركه
العملاقه ولكن ما تم الاعلان عن الدوله
اللي راح يشملها وقيل انه فقط في دول
اوروبيه وبالنسبه للاسباب التي اجبرت
الشركه على اتخاذ هذا القرار فتحدث رئيس
الشركه انه بسبب الوضع الاقتصادي غير
المؤكد انه خلال
والناس كانت فيها ببيوتك كان معظم عمليات
الشراء تتم عبر الانترنت
وباعداد كبيره جدا وبالتالي الان وب
بالانكماش الاقتصادي وغلاء تكلفه المعيشه
وتخفيض العملاء لانفاقهم فلازم يكون في
استغناء عن بعض الموظفين بحلول 18 يناير
الحالي وكانت الشركه طبعا توقفت عن تعيين
الموظفين خلال العام الماضي واتخذت خطوات
لاغلاق بعض من اعمالها والغاء مشاريع مثل
روبوت التوصيل الشخصيه ومشاهدنا لازم
نذكركم انه مش بس امازون عم بتخطط للتسيح
فمن قبل كان متى وسناب شات ومايكروسوفت
وجوجل واكد ما راح ننسى التسريح اللي خرب
الدنيا تصيح موظفي تويتر
عن هذه المجزره الوظيفيه المرتقبه تنضم
الينا من عمان الدكتوره رولا عواد خبيره
الهندسه البشريه اهلا بك استاذه رولا
حدثينا عن هذه المشكله في امازون وهل كان
ذلك متوقعا بعد كورونا
يعطيكم الف عافيه هلا هي هاي المجزره اكيد
ما كانت متوقعه بالطريقه هذه ولكن التخبط
اللي كان موجود وعدم ااا يعني وضوح الطريق
لا هذه الشركات هي اللي ادت لها المجزره
هاي عم بتوصلها لهذا المكان
التخبط هذا هو ما كان متوقع للمرحله نهايه
المرحله المتقدمه هاي وهذا طبعا رح يؤدي
سلبا همم يعني بامكان الشركات او حتى على
الاقتصاد العالمي بشكل عام
وهذه شركه عم نشوف انه كبرها الشركات
الهايتك
جوجل
تحديات وعم بتعان هالايام هل فينا نقول
انه هي وصلت للبيت
عمليات تقليص ام هي فرحه مرحله مؤقتا
لا هي مرحله خلينا نحكي انها مؤقته ومش
مرحله مش البيك يعني هي ما وصلت البيكو عم
تخسر ولكن هي مرحله بتمر فيها بعد التخبط
اللي صار من الوباء اللي صابنا اللي هو
الكورنا صعب الشركات صعب الاقتصاد والازمه
الاقتصاديه اللي حطت بعد ذلك هو سببها
وهذا كله بيادي يعني همم انهيار النظام
الراسمالي وبيادي كثير اشياء راح تكون
سلبه على المجتمع الانساني يعني ممكن انه
ترجع عنا لبريتال البريتاريا الحديثه غير
هيك ممكن كمان يعني نحكي انه في شركات راح
تندمج مع بعضها في شركات رح تخسر همم يعني
همم راح تخسر الوظائف اللي موجوده عندها
او حتى هتخسر وجودتها وكان يونتها
بالاقتصاد العالمي وهون عم نحكي عنهيار
لا انظمه ووجود انظمه جديده
يعني وضوح الرؤيه بالنسبه لهم بالطريقه
الصحيحه واكبر دليل على ذلك انهم اليوم عم
بروحوا قسم الموارد البشريه اللي هو خلينا
نحكي يعني الرئه الرقبه المسؤوله عن تحريك
الجسد اللي هو الشركات الموجوده في العالم
ما بيصير احنا نحكي انه قسم كامل بدير
يعني هو مسؤول عن اداره القوى العامله همم
بنحكي انه بدنا نروحه ما في له داعي وما
له ذلك هون عم نحكي عن سوء اداره سوء
تخطيط وعلى همم يعني همم زي ما حكينا راح
يؤدي للبروليتاريا وراح يؤدي الى المواطن
العالميه بسبب يعني انعدام وجود بعض
الشركات واندماج البعض الاخر
الهندسه البشريه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الامير هاري صار عنوان رئيسي من عناوين
البرنامج لانه على ما يبدو القناه اللي عم
يفجرها ما عم بتخلص قبل يومين من اصدار
كتابه
مستمر
وفضائح العائله الملكيه فمن يومين شفنا
كيف فضح الدنيا وقال انه عائلته ما بدها
اياه وانه هو عم يبحث عن عائله
ويليام في عام 2019
ما خبر زوجته باللي صار ولكن هي اكتشفت
الجروح على جسده ولكن لما نخبرها قال انه
هي ما تفاجات ولا حتى انصدمت طبعا الطاسه
التفاصيل راح نعرف جميعا في الكتاب راح
يصدر يوم الاحد والظاهر انه راح يخرب
الدنيا ببريطانيا وفجر الامير هاري مفاجاه
الثانيه بانه اقول مالك لما ولدت الاميره
حرثيا انه الان انجبت له ولي العهد
والاحتياطي وبالتالي انجزت عمله يعني مصر
الامير هاري على انه هو الشخص الاحتياطي
في العائله المالكي وهذا السبب كما هو
متوقع لتسميه كتابه بهذا الاسم والبعض
بيقول انه هذا اللقب الاحتياطي تسبب له
عقد نفسه
[موسيقى]
فصل قصير
اهلا بكم من جديد في مقطع فيديو متداول
الفنان العرب محمد عبده عامل التفاعل كبير
جدا بين السعوديين على المنصات خلينا نشوف
مع بعض مقطع منه
[موسيقى]
الصحراء
احضنت ترمالها
[موسيقى]
واطعمتني
ثم
رها افرشت لي
هيه ظلالها
ما منها الارض
انا
منها الارض
منها
[موسيقى]
الان اللي مالي عيالها
الفيديو اللي شفتوه كان اثناء تكريم فنان
العرب محمد عبده بجائزه التميز الاعلامي
لليوم الوطني 2022 بنسختها الثالثه وخلال
التكريم فنان العرب غلبته المشاعر ودموعه
وخنته الكلمات ولم يستطع التعبير من بعد
ما قال هذا الوطن الذي وجدني يتيما ونحن
في تفاعلكم نوجه له التحيه للفنان محمد
عبده ومن بيرك له على التكريم واكيد محمد
عبده كان وما زال اللحن والصوت الذي اطرب
كل العرب
[موسيقى]
الفنانه المصريه منه شلبي وقضيه التي شغلت
الراي العام المصري والعربي اليوم
بحيازه مواد مخدره تم ضبطها معها وهي
قادمه من نيويورك في مطار القاهره الدولي
ومن بعد ما تم الاستماع الى شهاده الشهود
وما توصلت اليه تحريات الشرطه وفحص المعمل
الكيماوي للمواد المخدره للمعه حاله
النيابه العامه المصريه الى المحكمه
الجنائيه بتهمه تعاطي المخدرات وتم اخلاء
سبيله بكفاله ماليه لحين انتهاء المحاكمه
اليوم مشاهدينا بدات اولى جلسات المحاكمه
مع الفنانه منه شلبي كلها
ما يطلب معاقبته بين من يتلمس العفو عنها
طبعا المحاكمه من تحت ومن شلبي محضره
الجلسه الاولى للمحاكمه وناب عنا محاميه
الدكتور محمد بهاء اللي حاول خلال الجلسه
التاكيد على انه المواد التي كانت بحقائب
المتهمه مش الى انه التفتيش الجمركي كان
خارج عن الضوابط والشروط واهم ما انه بدنا
شلبي ما كانت موجوده اثناء التفتيش وبعد
الانتهاء من الجلسه اصدر القاضي حكم على
منه شلبي بالحبس لمده سنه مع وقفه وغرامه
ماليه تصل قيمتها لعشره الاف
[موسيقى]
انطلقت باول من يناير في السعوديه فعاليات
النسخه الثانيه ليالي الدرعيه الي بتستمر
حتى 22 فبراير وبتضمن انشطه ثقافيه وفنيه
ورياضيه ومتنوعه وبتنقل الزوار لتجربه
اجواء شتويه فريده من نوعها في المملكه
بالاضافه لتذوق اشهى الماكولات في عدد
كبير من المقاهي والمطاعم الراقيه امبارح
كان نجم نادي النصر الجديد كريستيانو
رونالدو
وزير الرياضه السعوديه الامير عبد العزيز
بن تركي الفيصل وتم تداول عدد من المقاطع
الفيديو لا تواجد كريستيانو رونالدو
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله
دون خلالها حفل تقديمي في الملعب المرسول
بارك كره قدم من توقيعه وكان اختار من بين
الف الحضور ونحن في تفاعلكم فردنا بلقاء
خاص مع الطفله ننصحكم تتابعوه لانه في
اخبار جميله
[موسيقى]
وجع كريستيانو رونالدو وعدد من الكور خلال
حفل تقديمي في ملعب مرسول مبارك لكن هذه
الكره كانت لافته الذهب كريستيانو رونالدو
وانتقل طفله صغيره من بين الاف الاشخاص
الذين تواجد في الملعب هذه الكره هي
لعاليه لها عشان بس ما تزعل علينا وعليها
هي الطفله الوحيده التي او الشخص الوحيد
حتى في الملعب الذي ذهب اليه كريستيانو
واعطى الكره اليوم
انت ناديتي كريستيانو ولا كريستيانو هو
الي جاك
لما جاك انت عارفه انه حيعطيك الكوره
الناس اللي وراني ولا جنبي ولا
من كريستيانو رونالدو لكنك انت عملت حركه
عشان اختك ما ترجعها لكريستيانو ايش اللي
صار
تحس بيلعب معها
وانا ما كنت فيه بابا اللي قال لها ما
ترجعها ايه ايه فانا كنت في الجزء يعني
شويه الجهه الثانيه بعيد مره
وجيت وهي معها الكوره كل احد
يتجمع عليها يبغى الكوره يبغى يصور
لمن اخذتيها كيف الناس
كلهم يناظرهم في الكوره اللي معك ايه
عشان كده حسين الكوره اللي معك مهمه
[موسيقى]
عشان كده بتبيعنها لي صح
بعد محاولاتي مع عبد الله لشراء الكره
لانها بعت بالفشل الان مع ابو عبد الله
ابو عبد الله نرحب فيك
يعني زين اني انا قدرت اني اخذ الكره
بس عاد قويتهم
جدا جدا جدا
[موسيقى]
ختام الحلقه شكرا للمتابعه